the Joe Rogan experience yeah I find
Eddie I've always found Eddie really
interesting he's a trip he's a trip and
you can tell he's a thinker you know
that man he's a very analytical guy a
very analytical grappler with great
flexibility I just always would watch
him go this guy's [ __ ] slick man he
knows a lot of [ __ ] especially when it
comes to jujitsu and I'm talkin you know
I'm gonna see him tomorrow morning
oh really what are you doing you know
Sam I'm triply sure no Sam very well
yeah so I'm doing that show and he's
gonna be there I want him to explain
Flat Earth to me he's not going to be
able to I want to know but this is what
it is Eddie thinks that everybody's
lying that everybody in NASA and the
government and he because of that I
believe he has a blind spot and that he
if they're telling you the world's
around he's saying well it can't be
wrong right and it's not a good way to
think no but it's the same reason why
he's so good at jujitsu because he sees
an idea and he just pursues it and
chases after it he just is like it's all
you know it's all quantify it's all
right their two bodies it's all very
simple there's no mystery right you know
it's just a figure it's just figuring
out a puzzle yeah but I can see how
people get that way because I was a guy
who you know not to go off on a tangent
but I think it's fun to think about in
1971 when I was you know a young boy
standing in line in albia Iowa with my
grandma and my mom when the farm
collapse was happening when Nixon took
us off the gold standard right [ __ ] fell
apart for the farmers right away and my
grandma was one of the first people in
line to get her money out of the farmers
National Bank in Albi Iowa and she got
it out and I remember still to this day
standing there and asking my mama my
grandma what the hell is going on why is
this happening what's going on you could
see the panic the farmers went four
blocks right from all around that part
of Iowa and it just I think that's what
started the wheels turning in my head
about being a contrarian thinker well
there's real conspiracies and there's
real things where people misunderstand
the the actual facts right flatter it's
not one of them no it's not just I mean
there's so many stunning looks snipers
use the curvature of the earth to
calculate ballistics yeah it's just it's
just it's a real thing
Rayo I mean there's plenty of [ __ ]
that's not real but I want to tell me a
thing I want him to explain it's gonna
be frustrating anymore he might have let
it go by now I'm hoping he did right I
don't talk to him about it anymore I
just we had a few conversations about it
on the podcast and initially he thought
it was stupid he thought the Flat Earth
concept was too but and then all of a
sudden he started being open-minded to
him like what the [ __ ] are you saying
like what the [ __ ] are you saying this
is crazy and he's like he keeps going to
the fake the moon landing they're like
son of me the same people right like the
if they did that was a long [ __ ] time
ago you're talking about people right
now there's satellites all over the
world they there's a lot of people that
think satellites are fake I think Eddie
thinks dinosaurs aren't real yeah Wow
yeah you know it's interesting and I'd
never and the first time I fought in the
UFC I went into thanks dinosaurs yeah it
hurts hurts my head I went into the the
production trailer at my first UFC I
wanted to see what was going on in there
right that was that always intrigued me
how TV was put together right and I was
lucky enough to bring my daughter to one
of our broadcast with access TV and
Lonnie who's he's the expert to find the
satellites mm-hmm he's got an app on his
phone have you ever seen guys do that no
he has an app on his phone where he can
punch it in and do this across the sky
and spot all the the satellites right Oh
interesting so he knows how to dial into
him call up know the the coordinates to
turn the the dish towards and lock onto
a percentage of the satellite
you know receptor to get that beam back
down all that sort of stuff so he was
teaching my daughter how all that stuff
was done and it was first time I'd ever
seen it was like this was pretty pretty
amazing stuff but yeah you can see the
curvature of the earth and how the
satellites are set across the horizon
right well you could track satellites
the thing is these guys don't even
believe in satellites here's what the
problem is if someone has no
interruption and they put together a
video and that video they're articulate
and they sound calm they use big words
and they show you images that they're
claiming show that the earth is flat
that there's an ice wall outside of
Antarctica that the government won't let
you go there they start saying all these
things if there's no one there you know
like Neil deGrasse Tyson type guy
there's go hey hey hey no that's
true and here's why and here's how we
know and here's what we found out and
here's a test you can do yourself and
here's how you can figure it out right
and here's weekís what you could find
online and here and like for the longest
time they were trying to say that there
was no full pictures of the earth that
the the earth like every photo you see
of the earth is a composite know there's
a [ __ ] Japanese satellite called the
Himawari aid it takes full full images
of the earth high resolution every 10
minutes
you can go google it you can watch them
there's that NASA has one too because
there's giant photos of the [ __ ]
earth from 22,000 miles out or whatever
the hell it is like it's right yeah it's
[ __ ] real like there's a lot of [ __ ]
to think about that's fascinating that's
not one of them
[Applause]